axiom one this will be the first
all-private crude mission at the
international space station the
four-person multinational crew is
expected to spend 10 days in space mark
strossman caught up with the missions
commander in their final days of
training
michael lopez alegria's astronaut resume
still sparkles 10 years after retiring
from nasa liftoff of the soyuz rocket
transporting micropes alegria four
flights 10 spacewalks 257
total days in orbit
you thought
that part of your life was over yeah i
mean i was very happy with my nasa
flying career and i want to go do
something different and
didn't realize it wouldn't be that
different now improbably at the age of
63 he's going back to space
lopez alegria will command axiom one the
first all-private mission to the
international space station spacex
provides the ride the rocket axiom space
manages the mission this really looks
like a government nasa mission from the
outside the difference is it's a private
company and these are private customers
and this is a real turning point in
human spaceflight
his crewmates axiom's customers are
american larry connor canadian mark
pathy and israeli etan stibbe
rich businessmen who paid axiom millions
to fly
we take our tool kit with us here at the
johnson space center we watched the crew
winding down months of training at the
space station mock-up when we go up
there we'll be camping so we'll lay out
our sleeping bag somewhere and in the
morning we'll roll it up and get to work
they plan to visit the real thing for
about a week
living working doing research alongside
professional astronauts these guys are
eager they're smart they want to perform
you've heard the criticism this is just
a bunch of rich guys on a space junket
why is this something more
than space tourism first of all i want
to say that i think there is a place for
space tourism it's just that's not what
this mission is about at all we need to
span the gamut of experiences from
somebody who just wants to have a little
taste to somebody who wants a seven
course meal
we're on a seven course meal plan
in other words a cosmic leap beyond blue
origin and virgin galactic's quick up
and down trips to the edge of space this
is something that is the full experience
and i think that there will be ever
increasing appetite for that ignition
axiom his employer is betting on it the
company has chartered three more spacex
flights the company's more ambitious
goal to build the first commercial space
station it will start out attached to
the iss we have a number of corporations
and companies who want to do research in
space
there's media interest in space it's a
long list of folks michael suffradini is
axiom's ceo he spent 30 years at nasa a
decade of that running the iss program
where does ax1 fit into the bigger
picture
of where you want to end up this is the
first step in a number of flights that
allow us to work with nasa to learn how
to operate together so that when our
module first module shows up we can just
jump right into it just like lopez
alegria and three space rookies soon
will jump into the iss
for cbs mornings mark straussman houston
it ain't cheap but it is historic